hey whoever came out of Arizona like
doing the music
why is he laughing bro
he's from Arizona too I mean we had a
MC Magic
don't know who the [__] that is shout
out to MC Magic though so he's a Mexican
artist who looks very popular
he's a legend he's a legend for sure
shout out to MC Magic uh we have he's
the biggest
guy named futuristic who had like a
little independent run that was good he
did on Jimmy Fallon show Once
we had uh then there was like this wave
where Ludacris signed Willie North
pulled the dtp
the game sign juice who now goes by
Richie Evans the 50 Cent has some guy
who blew it up well 50 signed a guy
named hot rod hot rod yeah hot rod had a
record with Mary J Blige called be easy
but hot rod is really from Sacramento oh
he's not from Arizona so he when he when
he signed a G Unit like he was living in
Arizona at the time he was a part of a
crew called the man up Squad and it was
cool you know but
I don't think we like really like he
still lives in Arizona but he wasn't
like an AZ guy right he was from Sac one
dot one guy he had that record body Mark
Willie North Pole that was that's Willie
North Pole who signed with Luda put it
he put an album out probably the biggest
deal we've ever had was woolly North
Pole put an album out through Def Jam
and dtp that I got I actually got to go
to the store and buy okay okay which is
like a big deal is he still around like
he's still I mean he's I don't think
he's making much music but he's still
around okay he's a legend you know um
this is one guy I just heard of as of
recently
um he was messing with slim 400 desert
Baby Desert baby I think he might be
like desert baby still incarcerated yeah
free free desert baby okay and then uh
Riley you ever heard of Riley Riley's
Riley is my boy yeah
I got a song with Riley blood shout out
Riley blood see I'm typing yeah he's a
good guy yeah yeah and like right now
there's like Chris Coke there's mercums
Riley there's uh who else is popping
[__] in AZ uh Jada pink and stuff
there's like a dope bubbling scene right
now I was like question
I'm talking to you I'm interviewing you
yeah but look why um why you think AZ
haven't had they shot very much crabbing
the barrel mentality very much so
probably I mean it's terrible do you
support it though you're from Asia
I'm for sure yeah I've had everybody
coming freestyle on my show I think that
um
I think that with these smaller markets
sometimes it's very easy to get wrapped
up in pointing your finger at everybody
else as to why your [__] ain't doing
what you should be doing so I always
tell artists like hey man you got to
take a [__] in your own hands like you
got to build fan bases that are in the
independent of you having
I mean I hate to break it to everybody
but getting your [__] played on the
radio don't make a difference right
right
and I tell people that all the time
Instagram shout out don't mean [__]
either they don't mean nothing it's like
bro you need people to buy into you you
need to build that catalog you need to
formulate your sound you need to figure
out how you're going to turn five fans
to ten and 10 into 20 over and over stop
because a lot of times like I'll get
people like man [__] bootleg Kev he
ain't put me on his [__] and I'm like
bro like
I I always tell people just because
you're from Phoenix don't mean you just
get to come on my [__] right I gotta
just like be a fan of what you're doing
I gotta [__] see what you're doing
and I gotta be like oh [__] okay yeah
pull up and I've had hella people from
Arizona motion hella people but it's
just a matter of like I think with a lot
of those smaller markets that tends to
be the cases those are crab in the
barrel cities unfortunately because
there isn't nobody knows better we
haven't had somebody really pop to be
like oh that's how it's done all right
right you know what I mean and I think a
lot of the guys who end up making this
[__] work on a bigger scale kind of
leave for a little bit and I think
that's with anywhere you know sometimes
you got to get out of your your comfort
zone and I also think too that um
once somebody start getting a little bit
of like they turn their nose up for sure
yeah oh he switched up all right well
what do you mean okay what are you
saying like but yeah I think I think
Arizona's a definitely crabbing the
barrel mentality uh it's getting better
and a lot of people are working with
each other now and it's definitely um
you know because what Arizona I just
know it's Phoenix
uh Tucson so Tucson's an hour away hey I
know right uh we really don't
consider them the same
like Tucson and Phoenix there's two big
colleges that are like hardcore Rivals
so Tucson and Phoenix have a [__]
rivalry I'd rather [__] with Tucson
[__] than Phoenix [__]
I I feel you yeah I lost my virginity to
a Tucson [__] see in my dad's truck in
Tucson I met her in an MSN chat room
but the only thing is Tucson it's like
[__] desert is like country Tucson is
a Vibe it's just very small yeah
definitely there's definitely like
you're not gonna The Nightlife sucks
like the people from Tucson yeah like
one strip club like yeah and the strip
club's weird the last time I went it was
it was not a Vibe I just went oh no I
just when I went to Tucson
I just had hella fun like I mean it's
like a bar town it's a bar town like
yeah I mean I've had fun in Tucson I
mean like and like you said you it's
it's you could pull in Tucson easy right
right they're like oh people are here
that aren't from here like oh look at
you they'll get you some EGS
what isn't that EG's is the name of the
drink they got
yeah it's called EG's yeah Tucson is its
own thing
it's its own thing man Sunshine is a t
it's a good tweak but yeah you know all
the Arizona's like hardcore like you
know especially Tucson but so without
Tucson and Phoenix like where do y'all
go in AZ and we're not talking about the
tempees and [__] that's around Phoenix
like Mesa none of that like besides that
it's over with I mean you could go to
Flagstaff [__] Flagstaff who goes to
Flagstaff like what's in Flagstaff you
could snowboard uh there's Sedona which
is beautiful
go to Sedona and trip trip balls there's
like a bunch of spiritual vortexes and
[__] and let me show you Sedona is
[__] beautiful so
okay where would Drake do a show at
besides Phoenix to Arizona Tucson
besides Tucson
oh okay it's all a bunch of red rocks
and [__] right right no they're nowhere
else
maybe Flagstaff maybe at NAU maybe at
the college okay but now
there's Phoenix Arizona is literally
Phoenix right and then a bunch of
just Tiny Places I mean Tucson's a cool
Tucson's cool it's not like a [__]
hole in the wall it's Phoenix Tucson and
nowhere else
there's Yuma there's the Grand Canyon
which I've never been to and I'm from
Arizona to your club but let's talk
about that sure whenever I want to come
have a drink and I want to come you feel
me to do the whole experience I've seen
cardi B you feel me James Harden like
what the [__] like I'm low blood can I
come I'm trying to think the next time
I'm I think I'm gonna be there next
weekend
I think we have
we're working on a big booking next week
and I can't say but yeah next weekend
next week I'll be there Saturday between
you wanna go to AZ tots
yeah
it's hot right now
how long is that drive it's like 10
hours 12 hours [__] that boys